[Music]
okay hi everyone so i'm grandmaster
brian smith at the st. louis chess chess
club and this is romantic chess this is
just from from from up to about the year
1880 so for this week i'm going to show
a really a couple of funny games and i
think if we have time also a couple of
problems where the whole game wasn't
worth showing but the common final
combination was good so first we'll
start off with a game eight off anderson
against max lanka
now Adolph Anderson's player who played
the evergreen game and the immortal game
- two of the most famous Romantic era
chess chess games and well I'm not
showing those because they're so well
known but this is a lot less well-known
and he lost this game against another
player of the day not so is quite as
well as much remembered but also his
name is for instance the la MARCKS longa
attack as in some two knights gambit was
gunned down in history anyway this is
his game as black against Anderson so
Anderson started off be 45 Knight f3
knight c6 by the way this game was 1859
Breslau and it was some sort of informal
match or something like that I don't
know anyway so Bishop b5 it's actually
an open normal opening no Kings gambit
this time no Evans gambit a Spanish a
Rui Lopez which was one of the most
ancient openings perhaps the second most
ancient after the bishops opening that
we know of
94 so it's we're gonna see if we get to
it one of the problems by a player named
Henry bird and this is this this defense
is named after Henry bird this is birds
birds defense so blacks idea is what
moves his night twice but he changes the
pawn structure oops and leaves this
Bishop hanging out on b5 of course the
pawn structure is slightly inferior for
black now White has this kind of a clear
plan on the Kings side with f4 and some
day some cases also c3 could sometimes
lead to this pawn being exchanged and
whites gaining elite in development and
incentives central superiority but there
are points for black as well of course
this pawn in the meantime slows White's
Knights development on c3 and it opens
up the e-file it opens up some
possibility to hit the bishop and Queen
often comes to h4 so okay white went
Bishop c4 who knows what if white plays
d3 right away here well ok d3 hustle but
if white plays c3 with this plan of
undermining the pawn what would black
play here yeah duck Queens you fight
yeah so this is first trap of the
opening Queen can come out attacks the
bishop and attacks g2 and white doesn't
want to play Bishop f1 so castles is the
main move but white played Bishop c4
anticipating this attacks from the
bishop c6 also that thing and probably
intends c3 so black played Knight f6
attacking the pawn on e4 and here I
guess normal move would be either
castles or d3 but white decided to play
e5 which is a move which I think
nowadays wouldn't be preferred so much
because it's a this whole thing looks a
little shaky
more likely d3 castles I guess the idea
Knight takes e4 bishop of seven minister
how this turns out
Queen h5 white gets the piece back I
guess yeah gets the piece back because
you can 25 check or if King f6 and Queen
f3 and King e5 I don't believe that
so of course black doesn't have to take
the pawn you can but anyway so white
play d5 so black played d5 of course
hitting back this is this is a typical
method in open games 94 we don't want to
play because of things like there's 55
I'm not sure he's even the most
punishing because Knight g5 984 Bishop
f7 I was what I was first thinking about
it yeah maybe Bishop d5 maybe maybe even
just castles and queen up three there's
d5 black defends because he takes d6
Knight 66 Bishop f7 is possible and
Queen of three Knight of 6
takes Queen takes mr. this I think we
just after 94 we just will just leave it
hanging castles and now black you know
face some of the same problems but
anyway that's black black played this
typical replied d5 this is the best of
all you get a foothold in the center
attack the bishop on c4 if white takes
on f6 black takes here and these two
pawns are actually very strong and black
has two bishops on a wide-open board if
let's say white blacks threatening to
take if check Bishop e6 goes nowhere
if takes Bishop takes g7 or perhaps we
throw in Queen e7 is also possible throw
in queenie seven but in any case it's a
very good position for black these has
got two bishops on an open board and
these pawns are extremely strong now
this whole pattern reminds me of what's
called the max language well max longa
attack but it's a different position
night and night under Sun f3 and knight
on c6 and so it's a different situation
but that one's lit makes and whites
already castles within that one also so
bishops on c5 so as you included several
more moves in that case but here white
played Bishop b3 and black now did
something kind of wild here normal move
would be Knight g4 and actually black
stands very well here this is just a
great position for black pawn on e5 is
hanging and Queen h4 might become in
response you know
various move so white has some white
White's doesn't stand that well here but
black made a really wild creative but
also a little bit a little bit too
abrupt move Bishop g4 kidding the White
Queen
well White Queen is trapped except White
has F three and now two pieces are under
attack
I'm sure that's long ago took this into
account because now he played 94
otherwise he's he's just losing a piece
right for not enough compensation so he
jumped into this forking his own pieces
it's already move a only move eight and
already things are getting a little bit
jovial here so what do you think White's
gonna do here Castle we got a castle
because if if we take on g4 Queen h4
check yeah and so we're not gonna do
that FG three of course what is black
play Knight takes g3 and whites white
zoom yeah yeah so so now the rooks
hanging and of course aged six g3 Queen
six h1 White has two pieces for a rook
but his Kings being bumped around the
board there's gonna be another Queen g2
Queen takes 3/3 with check and so that's
a lot of pawns and continuing attack so
that's not good for white so he castled
okay I'm gonna turn off this thing for a
second because we have so we don't see
black now okay his Bishop and Knight are
both under attack mm lunga probably saw
this far these guys were not we're not
dumb people they didn't have the benefit
of several centuries of chess knowledge
they're finding their own way in the
opening but they calculated and they
came up with ideas and they they had an
even if they didn't have a lot of books
they had a natural sense and he didn't
just work his own pieces for nothing
what do you think blacks idea was yeah
Bishop c5 okay that's an idea but white
could easily shut that down with just d3
right and now not that we need to attack
the knight on e4 again
but now we've we're definitely forking
those two pieces and we're winning one
of them and I don't see anything at all
for black here Knight c3 you could try
but then that's a little that way that's
the kind of move it someone might think
about but that's not gonna lead anywhere
because we just we just blocked a check
and now we're gonna win another piece so
so Bishop c5 we want to do but we don't
want to give white chance for d3 so what
do you think d3 yeah so that's what long
got played
however white has a refutation which he
didn't find what do you think white
played here or what do you think white
should play here rather this is a little
bit harder yeah Queeny one yeah very
good
queenie one in order to see this move we
have to recognize what blacks intention
is which we'll see in a moment but
queenie one would refute it so what's
the point why queenie one yeah same work
same person who answered before to
remove the pin but there's another I
mean we can take the bishop right away
right that's what he did yeah partially
but not exactly there's yeah kind of
yeah that too but also one more square
that we is actually the most important
to control yeah not exactly but that's
also we would we'll see that we need to
control the squared g3 okay
not so much f2 not so much h4 but g3 but
that'll become clear in a moment okay so
instead of that queenie one white with a
refuted black's attack but white
actually took on g4 so now of course
check on c5 king h1 what do you think
black played I kind of gave it away now
93 now right Queen h4 would not have
worked here it wasn't so much to control
h4 or to control f2 because F night F to
check just White's already up a piece
Knight F two White's going to take
blacks gonna take and here White's got
two pieces for a rook but it's Kings not
being chased around in fact it's after
Queen of three it's white who's going to
be with the initiative attacking the
bishop and also the pawn on d5 and the
pawn on d3 why it's just winning here
we're up White's up a lot of material so
not that and not even Queen h4 what
would white do after Queen h4 Queen e1
would allow Queen trade and then night
of to check and then take on take on c2
hitting the night and after Bishop takes
the 93 King maybe even maybe even
Queenie one is possible actually Queenie
one night of hmm yeah Bishop f2 right
yeah this should very good bishop of two
well even then rook takes it takes King
II one night h3 King f1 is but it's
still maybe Queenie one even I'm not
haven't checked that but there's no
point in because there's a better
defense that ends at all for black yeah
Queen f3 yeah now all that stuff is not
working night f2 just allows rook takes
and white is just again the same thing
as before the ending is bad for black if
Queen f2 we trade Queens we take the
pawn on d5 and then white should win
pretty easily to pieces against a rook
and also an extra an extra pawn for
white well it is in addition and Bishop
takes f2 is no different black runs out
of attackers so 90 to g3 however first
not giving a white to chance to do those
things so why just to take it what do
you think black plays here
Queen g5 yeah each 5 is also tempting
but I guess after h5 white keeps it all
closed with g5 well yeah it takes a take
is gonna be met bike it's going to clean
too it takes can be met by Queen g5 and
and White's losing right takes Queen g5
g for mate Queen h4 so yeah but g5 white
would play age for g4 but eventually
didn't work right and and also we don't
have to play g3 I just did that for
comedic effect but Queen f3 would be
good too right huh we could even take on
h3 you're right yeah yeah no one wants
to take the pawn but we could once they
get stage 3 right so okay so that didn't
work but Queen g5 locking that pawn in
place and threatening what was white
wears black threatened Queen h6 made
right so white has to do something about
that there's only one move rook f5 right
you only move what do you think black
plays here we need six rook each if
Queen aged six location h6 is a funny
move but unfortunately for black and
chest captures are not are not
obligatory so white would do something
else like I don't know yeah after age
six I'm sure white can have with the
extra tempo probably can defend somehow
Cringer yeah but Blackwood yeah Quincy
one is green G one is actually working
I'm not sure it's the only defense but
because white already had an extra piece
right there'll be two pieces against the
rook
so after but H five right so black
played H fight we all saw that so H 5 so
now white had to take because this is
all the thread is to take on g4 of
course if white takes the Queen then
it's gonna be checkmate age 64 and check
my next so a G takes h5 what is black
play here we can takes remember the rook
is x-ray on h5 so rip takes isn't gonna
work on each try we've got to take the
rook now still white has two pieces for
a rook right unless I miscounted you
have two pieces for a rope so he plays
g4 has has to stop rook takes h5 our
queen takes h5 now what is black play
Queen g5 is gonna give white I'm no
Queen f2 enough to Weah maybe winning
also I think at this point there's but I
mean let's see so you know I don't want
to ruin this by having there be mold
more than one bit win but I can't do
anything about it
maybe Queen f3
but then Queen e1 and Queen g1 minimum
huh Queen j1 is mate yeah very good mmm
there might be more than one win here g3
I guess but it's definitely winning for
black right so I yeah black and just
take it's definitely winning for black
right so I mean it should be the you
know okay so you're gonna take Queen f1
they can do for ya it's all over and
this is what can we do
it's uh but that's the way that's the
thing about these a lot of these games
are just going to be there was the
instead black found a much more a much
more dramatic way to do it so it takes
pawn again right pawn takes and now
Queen f2 white can go g4 hello g4 Queen
h4 King G two queens guarding g1 at this
moment so yeah I mean if Queen of - I
guess g4 I don't think I don't know
about this but there's no need Reed's to
sacrifice the rug that's not why you
sacrificed the rook there's a better
move Queenie for ya pinning the pawn on
g2 so now there's no g3 no g4 moves
Queen h4 mate is a threat so white fleet
Queen f3 there's no other Queen h4 yeah
Queen e1 bishop g1 yeah not letting the
King get out and then wipe resign
because yeah so yeah in so if we look at
this position yeah when I looked I saw
Black has multiple ways to win of course
but I hope that no one would just point
out the obvious Queen f2 but in a
certain way this is forcing also this is
more forcing because we can look at this
is forest and clearly after Queen e4
white doesn't have as many defenses as
it would have after Queen of two even if
the ones after Queen of two also fail
what's that yeah the development yeah
it's pretty bad so yeah we learning
about we're learning about some some
development here so okay so was a was a
pretty nice game I guess kind of in a
way yep okay let's see another one now
this one also unfortunately has the same
aesthetic flaw yeah I don't exactly
remember all the first few this is the
same kind of aesthetic flaw that black
had a simple win but it's also very nice
game so this was Fisher versus steinitz
so your ears don't deceive you Fisher
did not return or didn't I go back in
time or steinege didn't come forward in
time to play the match that's everyone
wish would happen but this is someone
with it with the letter C missing from
his name Fisher with an SH so it is from
ass I'm 11 t2 so Steinitz was black this
is the first world champion what's that
Stein it's had black yeah oh you can see
yes Dinitz had black fischer was just a
was not Bobby Fischer obviously this was
someone from that time period
who was just an amateur presumably you
should see four so he played the bishops
opening f5 not a move Steinitz would
probably play in tournament game
although he played some kind of wacky
opening sometimes even though he was
known as a very serious defender like to
take upon and survive in his early days
he was actually a very sharp attacking
player and the same styles as Anderson
and and these these other guys even
later he liked to play those Steinitz
gambit he 45 f4u takes f4 Knight c3
Queen h4 King e2
so here here you decided to play a five
he wants the center okay it's to do
dubious move to put it lightly but it's
white decided to refute it immediately
with Bishop takes g8 which is probably
not the best choice giving up a bishop
of course he wants to check on each five
but that's not really sufficient
justification black took black can't
Castle this is correct but he doesn't
need to in this game in fact even his
King will take part in the attack within
twenty twenty four moves his King will
be attacking the white king white took
on f5 okay check on h5 might have been
White's intention but and he realized
that this was really not that good for
him he could take enough money for also
ninety-six with the idea of an 84 or
black could just take on he for the
white queen on h8 is maybe a slight bit
of an annoyance but it's also not it's
all by itself so it's not gonna really
be able cause too much harm for black
and meanwhile black is gonna take over
the rest of the board I also like just
developing ninety six ninety four it
also is even more in the spirit of
things
white white took on a five winning upon
this way black Wendy five now Queen h5 I
mean if he doesn't do this black takes
back on that five and he gets a dream
position two bishops and the center and
while he can't castle hill probably
Castle queenside or leave his King in
the center for a little while but that's
that's fine but whites whites also not
going to his King faces an uncertain
future between age five check g6 white
took on g6 so if he took on h7 black
would go rook g7 followed by Bishop
takes f5 and again that dream position
and that case Plex in that case Plex
down upon but again with whites Queen
being where's the Queen going went okay
has to go here and then Bishop takes f5
probably and whites has black has lots
of compensation for the pawn he's going
to play knight c6 developed the Queen
Castle Queen said white zone Queen can
even be trapped in the future and also
c2 as a target and
because they're all those other
advantages so he white took on g6
Blackfoot back with a rook and now white
most likely noticed Queen takes e5 is
met by who knows this is not too hard
check rook rook e6 right so he if he
took on age 7 he could take on age 7 but
then probably Bishop a5 again probably
Bishop f5 and again black has like as
White's Queen is running all over the
place black as development center in for
compensation for now it's two pawns but
I still like blacks position he'll his
king will get to the Queen side also g2
is hanging and maybe can take on g2 but
then there's Queen h5 check so I didn't
want to allow that just do this oh you
also have rook h6 as well and if Queen
g8 Bishop e6 with even more Tempe gain
and if Queen goes back to d3 then black
could continue I mean I would probably
just play this though I guess anyway so
92 white played deciding probably just
now it's time to develop a little bit
black played knight c6 developing a
piece and white castles so his King got
out of the center but that's not going
to be that's not going to be everything
that's not going to be enough to keep
white safe King can come under attack on
the King side as well especially with a
half black having open lines their
Bishop g4 gaining a move attacking the
Queen White's invited in fact forced to
take on h7 but his Queen now is going to
be buffeted it all over the board
took on h7 Ric h6 black saves the rook
Queens under attack and the knight is
also under attack on e2 so the only move
is queen d3
now black continued let's listen let's
close this now and see the so we can
start doing some problems so queen d3 so
okay
black began with e4 queen III is forced
now what should black play we're gonna
keep the initiative going I think white
has two pawns right but really needs to
get something some attack so what do you
think Queen h4 okay Queen h4 is probably
pretty good
but after h3 it's now what one person at
a time
yes in the back I can't hear who see
really very well but yeah Bishop f3 but
it's not it's not forcing don't have to
take it maybe then Knight
maybe just it's probably pretty bad for
white also I mean maybe d3 Bishop c5 in
Bishop g2 I didn't know it should c5
Queen takes 86 extra so there should be
six now I take the rook I've opened up a
little something there
rook g6 Knight f4 d4 Knight to g6
say hitting the Queen maybe the last
move d4 I was thinking about but anyway
let's it's not as good as what he played
we don't need to be so fancy he found a
way to develop his attack further
without needing to get involved in all
that stuff so it's actually we think
like well this is just a crushing
position it looks really crushing but
when he Stein it's played in assignment
the sign will by the way it was actually
pretty accurate I don't know Queen h4
I'm sure he's good for black as well but
he found a very clear way of developing
an initiative which was absolutely
forced and destroyed White's position in
the back yeah
Bishop where ship d6 I can take the rook
right yeah he wanted he made a move
which was actually on this sorry the I
think I erased all the moves oh no he
did he did he did this okay sorry don't
look okay yeah he did this first but now
in this position what I was saying we
were looking at Bishop f3 we don't need
to do all this fancy stuff
he just took on e2 and now
94 so Queen has to guard c1c2 I mean and
save itself so Queen d1 is force Knight
f3 check okay so this is you know it's
not too hard to see but still we wanted
to play Bishop of three so so here now
this is the point where you might find
your queen f2 move like in the last one
which unfortunately puts a blemish on
the on the on the aesthetics of the game
so we can find that move where you can
find the move Steinitz plays what do you
think they're both equally good yeah we
enough for now we can just second Queen
a4 enough for might also be good
queen queen of four yeah this is also
yeah this this one's also Queen Queen
takes f3 either son yeah so this is uh
obviously winning for black also this is
very simple
that's that's one of the queen of two
moves and you said Queen takes h3 very
good that's of course that's the move
you played it can't be criticized
because it also wins
even though Queen of four or there's one
other move to which was the first move
ice that I said okay that Queen g4 also
is absolutely no defense for white to
rook takes h3 what's that I can't hear
you very well there's too many people
talking at once I'm sorry and I can't
hear so well from back there
Queen there's 56 we don't we don't need
what's that I mean I'm just maybe that
black swinging after that too but we can
get we get this move in yeah then it's
checkmate you're right okay so so
there's there's many there's many ways
for black to win here yeah yeah so Queen
takes h3 check
she takes h3 rook takes h3 King G to
check there should be six right
there's probably gonna be many ways to
win at this point - but I I'm sure that
there are many wins for black here like
king f7 is probably also probably also
good rook each one though I you have to
check that kind of stuff rook h1 then
rip g8 rook g5 is made so I'm sure king
f7 is also he's also a win but he first
checked here king f7 King e7 yeah yeah
he didn't do either of those as far as I
remember he did this one I'm sure
there's also various various ways here
as well I mean King f7 is his uh
threatening Rick f4 mate and if d3 rogue
h5 and what g4 okay so if d3 rook g8 no
I don't know then what h1
I'm sure there's 94 also come yeah rook
F 4 is a threat have to play d3 here
that's why G 8 yeah yeah 94 and rook
each fiber or both are both threats so
this was this was also a win so but he
preferred rook h5 forced in the king
even his aesthetic sense was very good
this day because he knew his opponent
wasn't gonna go back down with king g4
because then rook c5 and made on H file
right change is six so King was he
trying to go further up the board what
now again there's well the rook is
hanging this was probably less ways to
win but rook g5 okay so king went to f2
aged six because if king f6 then
Bishop e7 made her sorry King King King
e6 and in 94 mate right or rookie five
whichever you prefer
yeah King age six so King he actually
chose this one King f7 is also good but
he chose this one and then now King f7
Luke h1 Bishop g7 and apparently white
resigned which was just real
unfortunately should have played it out
until checkmate in the spirit of the
times
yes two moves yeah it's too much still
check me queen of three and then
checkmate mmm but yeah Queen f3 would
not be in the spirit of the times
okay let's so we've we've done those so
now let's see a couple of problems this
one is okay I'm gonna quickly get rid of
okay so this is black played this move
this is the game Mason versus win over
from Vienna 1882 yeah James Mason I
think yeah I'm swimming and we know
where's well we've seen in the last hour
the win over variation which is he was a
player of the Romantic era black played
rook f6 white has what two pawns more if
I can count right
two pawns more White's up two pawns but
on f5 the pawn is hanging the knight on
c5 is looking pretty solid
how does white win here
how are we going to break through and
break into blacks position after clean
of five blocks going to get some
counter-attacking ideas also maybe
coming in Queen f1 Rick and so someone I
can't hear if everyone's talking at once
and really quiet voices so someone needs
to raise their hand if they yeah what's
that rook takes g5 yeah rook g5 okay
that's what he played but we have to see
the follow up black takes and now what
queen h7 so if King g8 Queen eight shade
right sorry if King if King d8 we take
first unbe April well either way you can
do it but so king da does is either
Queen h8 or take first nb8 and then
Queen h8 and take the rook and whites
then up three pawns with a winning
attack so however black is gonna block
with this night
how does white play now
sorry what's and you want any ideas yeah
rook takes rook okay if rook takes rook
then if I play that move I think it's
going to show the right move so I don't
want to so rook takes rook King takes
remember it's a hole rook that's been
sacrificed
there's sixty-seven so the king is I
mean the Queen is over works right
covering be a dandy rook takes then then
King takes and if Bishop takes the Queen
moves maybe somewhere like to take c3
for instance and it's not so clear at
least right White has some pawns for the
exchange but maybe even Queen takes
Queen to King b6 but it's not as good so
we should take with a king but much
better is Bishop 67 right that's what he
did so if Queen takes t7 then we can
trade Queens and take on b8 which would
be three pawns up okay it's gonna be two
pawns after black takes on f5 but that's
it's still gonna be enough white will
see c4 and then take the a pawn on a
three and still then again beat if I'm
counting right or I was counting right
it'll be three pawns yeah anyway it's so
black played Queen g8 so now White's
down the exchange still it's got a
couple pawns for it but how do we win
here
Queen e7 is good and then rook f7
look see for ya and then and then the
King King moves somewhere and then white
takes on d6
I mean King b7 Bishop c6 check yeah
Queen d7 is also good but actually after
queen of psychic weeny 7 probably
probably I don't want to play the move
because it's going to show
so Queen e7 there's also Queen f7 and
then again rixie for King b6 hmm yeah
and this Y could even trade Queens here
have a couple pawns for the exchange but
there's actually a much clearer we can
go back to Queen e7 I don't want to
start entering the moves in because
because it's going to show the solution
in the little box that's gonna pop up
this way this is the whole point is to
see the solution Queen e7 is I think
pretty good for white Queen f7 rook c4
King b6 and then
and then Queen takes e4 and if Queen
takes d7 we have queen g4 check right
but black doesn't have to take on d7
basically White's winning yes three
pawns for the exchange and a continuing
attack it's completely winning actually
but there's better and what he what he
played was better
we could even Y could even trade Queens
and then play Bishop e6 and white should
win that right here for instance you
gonna pick off the e4 pawn and have
three pawns or maybe even four for the
exchange for pawns for the yeah four
pawns for the exchange that's just
winning so so this is a problem with a
lot of these old games there's just big
flaws but but there's a better move
actually technically better than that
and also more beautiful then trading
queen better move than Queen takes G
Bishop e6 and then rook takes e4 which
would be a slow and steady me and not
even that slow actually but yeah rook b7
yeah rook b7 okay look take a look - b7
if rook takes white takes the Queen and
then after King takes t7 Queen g7 right
that can't protect both rooks or either
Brooklyn f6 so you took with the king
and now yeah
let him let him say it says I yeah I
can't hear you what Bishop c8 yeah very
good
Bishop c8 Bishop c8 and that cuts off
the King from the Queen double check
right black played this of course if he
took then white would take the Queen and
it also forked the rook so he went here
and then white took the Queen and black
played this move as clever as possible
but he's losing now of course he was
already losing but he's definitely
losing this is easier than the exchange
down ending for four pawns or or the
exchange down ending with three pawns in
an attack both possible but this is
Queen z8f threatening mate black
protected but now Queen d7 of Queenie
Yeats you say yeah it might also yeah
then
Yuni eight then I guess yeah it's
probably better right
well there's rook peace no yeah yeah
Queen e8 of course is stronger
he played queen d8 it doesn't matter
it's still winning and now he played
Queen d7 yeah does the same thing into
me but it's okay whatever it's check on
still winning lacked at this well you
know Queen e8 I guess I guess there was
check on b1 and then rookie 5 but of
course White's winning then and there's
check on c6 and then take on d6 or where
f king a7 Queen a6 King be a queen d6
and pick up the rook anyway doesn't you
see it's winning either way did this and
then black did that but now check
he took here
protected through that predicted g2 and
a to everything guarded desperate move
and Bishop c4 next so that was that was
that okay we got time for one more okay
I still that was okay this was the this
was the great bird Henry Edward bird
against Berthold English from London
1883 here can anyone imagine what's
gonna happen anyone tell me what's gonna
happens White's actually is black to
move White's actually got some activity
as an extra pawn but it's sort of
meaningless but it's about easy to
imagine in a practical game black losing
this position somehow even if it's
technically just a little bit better for
white because you know got active rooks
the knight is stuck on e8 there's some
mating ideas possibly coming up the
black played rook g5
can anyone tell what what might happen
here you see what's what White's gonna
do oh you've seen the game okay then
don't don't tell it don't tell people
yeah rook takes c8 rook takes eight
Knight takes f6 and White's winning
right that's what's gonna happen
anyone see that what's what's the the
boomerang to that so rook takes he what
is black play that's what he did rook
takes key now to be fair it might be a
reasonable practical practical attempt
because here white doesn't have actually
any advantage for instance we're not
going to protect our Knight with King h3
right
I mean if King age 3 wreckage 5 is meat
so we'd have if white wanted to if
White's saw what black was gonna do
after rook takes he ate trying to play
for a win would still be you know you'd
have to retreat one of the rooks or the
knight or something like that and
realistically the chances of a winner
not too high so even if he saw what
black was going to do which apparently
he didn't but if even if he did see it
it was a reasonable practical attempt so
what is black play here takes the rook
no first we have to insert to check it's
very important King G 1 and now has to
take the rook right looks like blacks
got himself even into bigger problems
because now his rooks are forked and if
before of course if just to go back in
case you don't see here Knight takes f6
the point is checkmate on h7 as a threat
and also the rook is hanging and this is
covered now so black Canton but it looks
like after check first black got himself
even into bigger trouble but I think we
see what's gonna happen now what does
black play
yeah huh rook e1 king of two um if I
enter it again it's gonna show the right
move rook e1 king of two and then what
happens in check on f5 okay you're right
that's still enough for a draw
yeah the two pawns is a draw no rook e1
king of - okay I'll come back to it if I
think if I enter it it's gonna pop up
with a little button it's gonna show the
rook each one is the most correct rook
e1 this is this is immediate stalemate
right the two the double kamikaze rooks
okay but you're it's interesting because
I again I didn't look at the game very
critically rook e1 King f2 rook f5 check
we don't have to do any kamikaze rooks
this time King takes king rook takes
it's just a draw because doubled pawns
one pawn is the draw double pawns also
it doesn't make a difference
all black has to do is just
take his rook on the back or ink and
move back and forth because G pawns if
it was F pawns or I pause it would also
be a draw but black would have to use a
Philidor method with G pawns all he has
to do is just you know whatever white
does he just sits back there
rook just sits on the back rank and
there's there's no way white can play
for a win with you because there's no
weight no room on the eight further
beyond the H file doesn't matter with
the second one doesn't make a difference
okay I'm gonna do if I can figure out
how this sets let's just make I would
setup the position but I would say how
do I set up the position how do I set up
a new position from here s okay there we
go okay good so what do you want as far
as possible like this here
not sure you wanted to do like but how
are you gonna sue so you're gonna you're
gonna do this first but I'm gonna leave
my king here when you have this okay
let's let's set up you let's start with
this position start with this is your
okay with that okay put the pawn on d5
but it oops
so pawn on g5 noises I'm gonna leave my
king here first of all Justin I mean you
can chase it to TJ but you have to play
rook check first so okay let's this
position I'm gonna play this one I mean
you can always get to any position so
let's say that from here okay
I mean you don't want on g4 isn't gonna
help you right so let's start with g5 I
think it got it wait to move here I
understand you want to go when the Kings
on H say you want to go rook F a check
and g7 check force the trade and this is
guys back on g2 but I don't think it's
gonna happen not to mention the fact
that black could have still used
Philidor message and it's well known
that the two pawns it makes no
difference
but g6 okay so you want to check and
force the King here and then go here
threaten rook FA but I just go back yeah
if you try to go back with a rook I'll
wait and if you try to go g7 then I
checked you know if you drove rook on f6
okay and this is gonna have to be black
to move though or whites um yeah I guess
weights a movie consider well g7 so you
want this and this is here and it's
White's move let's make it White's move
a seven ok White's new g7 check no I
mean let me just I mean I might I might
be because I did let's let's put the
rook here but and this like that
and it's let's say it's White's move and
go g7 we threatened rook f8 so black has
to actually has to avoid that no yeah
yeah this is the one that black has to
work yeah but uh you know I won't let
that happen so I mean if you go rook f6i
I go rookie seven actually then you go
rook b6 yeah I could be I could be
completely delusional here and that this
point is actually makes difference in
that case we use the Philidor method
still we would we would just we just put
the rook on the on the sixth rank and
then it's well known draw so
okay okay and enjoy this and okay hmm
yeah this is yeah no no not here of
course yeah this has gone too far from
the starting position
now here this position yeah you're right
I mean you put the rook on them I feel
kinda I feel kind of stupid
I mean suggested because but I mean you
let's say you got I mean the Philidor
position very simple you just know of
course it's simple
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]